- This is some of the stock that we've got
for the Chinese market.
- [Narrator] Mitchell Taylor's
winery has been selling
Australian wine since the 1960s.
- It retails for approximately
a thousand dollars a bottle.
- [Narrator] And in the past five years,
China has been his main focus.
- That's the back label there
with all the Chinese details.
- [Narrator] But these
bottles can now be three times
as expensive, because China
has imposed new tariffs
of up to 212% on Australian wine.
- I was absolutely shocked,
it really did hit me hard.
- [Narrator] Since May,
Australia has been caught
in a tree dispute with China.
It isn't not just the wine industry,
but also coal, barley, lobster, and beef.
Some economists say as much
as 6% of Australia's GDP
hangs in the balance.
- It's an attack on free
countries everywhere.
- [Narrator] The bilateral
trade dispute has gone global.
China hawks and lawmakers from
across the political spectrum
and around the world, are
taking Australia's side.
The White House National
Security Council even tweeted
that it would serve Australian wine
at its holiday reception.
Politicians are jumping on
China's wine tariff to draw
a global attention to what
they see as Beijing's bullying.
And Australia's winemakers hope
this new coalition can help
save their industry.
- It's a great initiative.
The coalition of partners
can come together
and help us all put pressure
on the Chinese regime.
- The virus began in China in Wuhan,
that's I think well understood.
- [Narrator] This statement
is what sparked the dispute,
when back in April, the
Australian government called
for an investigation into the origin
of the coronavirus pandemic.
Beijing, which has suggested
that the virus came
from outside China,
dispelled the criticism.
(speaks in foreign language)
- [Narrator] But this diplomatic tussle
is about more than the virus.
China has pointed out several
grievances against Australia,
like when it banned Chinese telecom
from Huawei from its 5G network,
because it said to posed a
national security threat,
even though Huawei said
it has operated safely
in the country.
(crowd chanting)
And when Australia condemned China's
controversial national
security law in Hong Kong,
which Beijing said is a domestic matter.
So in May, China slapped
tariffs of up to 80% on barley,
followed by levies on other goods.
Timber exports were also
stopped at Chinese customs.
For entrepreneurs like Mitchell Taylor,
these tensions threaten their businesses.
A safe bet big on China, and
invested to expand production
by buying new land and
upgrading facilities.
- Our current sales
into the Chinese market
are about 10 to 15%.
We've been explaining our
wines and matching them
with the very good Chinese cuisine.
- [Narrator] Taylor says
sales in China have doubled
over the past four years,
as drinking wine became
a status symbol for the
Chinese middle-class.
To appeal to more Chinese drinkers,
Taylor adapted his product.
- The Chinese customers, they're
fascinated with technology.
We have a microchip here that
is a great security seal.
- Taylor also uses gold on labels,
which is perceived as
a lucky color in China.
He created heavy wooden boxes that he said
Chinese customers
associate with exclusivity,
and the company even produced
wines that Taylor says
Chinese consumers like
to have with hotpot.
Taylor's isn't the only
winery in Australia
to have bet big on China.
Exports there have tripled
in the past five years,
to hit $907 million in 2019.
Australia's economy as a whole
has come to rely on China,
sending a third of its
exports to the mainland.
- Australia has not had
an economic recession
in about two decades,
and much of that is
thanks to China's rise.
- [Narrator] Vicky Xu is an
analyst who's been studying
Australia's increasingly
tense relationship with China.
Despite the closer economic relationship
between both countries,
Australia's government
has been raising its voice
on political issues sensitive to Beijing.
- People in the business
community are very anxious
here in Australia.
And that the current
administration is speaking out
assertively on issues like human rights.
But the question is,
can we really stand up
for our values despite economic losses?
- We will not be bullied.
- This trade dispute,
especially China's wine tariff,
has caught the attention of a new alliance
of more than a hundred lawmakers
from more than a dozen countries.
They say trade policies shouldn't be used
as a political tool.
- We are asking you all
to join us in standing
against Xi Jinping's
authoritarian bullying.
- By drinking a bottle or
two of Australian wine.
- [Narrator] As trade disputes multiply
in a globalized economy, Vicky
Xu says countries that share
political values could increasingly rely
on each other's market.
- [Vicky Xu] Everyone
knows they will have help,
and they will have backup when
they're also being punished
by Beijing for perceived indiscretion.
- We really do appreciate our allies
and friends coming together.
We've got an opportunity now
to relaunch in the US market,
the UK and in Canada.
- [Narrator] But because
consumers there are different
from the Chinese, Taylor
is tweaking the marketing
around his lineup of more than 50 bottles.
- The labels in Chinese,
we'll have to rip them off.
We'll have to rebottle
it, and then repackage it.
- [Narrator] For the US market,
Taylor is using floral labels to appeal
to young urban consumers.
And will start exporting vegan wine
to cities like New York and Los Angeles.
And for the longterm,
he's planting more Shiraz and Grenache,
which are in popularity in the West.
Still, it will be difficult
to make up for lost business.
Some Australia-based
foreign policy analysts hope
with the incoming Biden administration,
like-minded countries could
work together to confront China,
as the president-elect
has said that he will seek
to strengthen global alliances.
- The idea that we're
gonna be able to deal
with China's rogue behavior,
when we make up 25% of
the world's economy.
Without bringing in the
other 40% of our allies,
is not realistic.
- [Narrator] Meanwhile,
China says it's committed
to free trade and that it's
tariff measures are in line
with international customary practices.
And that it's now up to Australia
to repair the relationship.
Taylor knows he's closing out a tough 2020
without the same access
to the China market.
But he says he's learned
a lesson for next year.
- This whole incident has really taught us
not to get too focused on one customer,
you've just gotta diversify and do that.